[Musique]
effectivement un goût d'inachevé dans ce
budget parce qu'on a eu un pdf dont on
va dire qu'il a aussi notamment avec
tout le plan de la relance
une mission importante un espèce de
budget bis qui fait que d'une certaine
manière les sénateurs en
un peu de mal à s'y retrouver en fait
comme les français c'est la valse des
milliards et pourtant il n'ya pas de
grandes lignes directrices finalement le
premier sujet c'est le sujet sanitaire
qui bouleverse tous et qui fait perdre
ses repères à l'exécutif et au
gouvernement
on le sait plus de 70% de
l'investissement public est porté par
les collectivités locales
eh bien le gouvernement en dehors
d'avoir passé un accord bilatéral avec
les régions n'a pas été au rendez vous
d'un pacte de confiance avec les
territoires
quand vous voulez créer une confiance
dans le pays il faut s'appuyer sur ses
forces ses forces ce sont les
territoires les collectivités locales
on s'est battu pour faire en sorte que
le maximum de compensations puisse être
obtenu pour ces collectivités elles ont
besoin elles aussi dans la difficulté
parce que il y à des dépenses nouvelles
pour les communes pour les
intercommunalités pour les départements
regard de ces dépenses nouvelles
le gouvernement finalement ne crée pas
ce sentiment de confiance et les
français ressentent et le pacte de
confiance
l'état aujourd'hui doit le passé
notamment avec l'ensemble des acteurs
des collectivités locales et avec des
entreprises avec les entreprises avec la
baisse d'impôts de production ce qui
permet aussi d'alléger je dirais cette
fiscalité qui pèse trop sur notre
activité économique et notamment sur la
compétitivité de l'économie française
ça je crois que c'est une ligne
directrice sur laquelle nous
continuerons nous de nous appuyer
on s'est attaché à conserver les
les termes de l'accord passé avec les
collectivités notamment avec les
départements
raison pour laquelle là où le
gouvernement voulait récupérer indûment
revenant sur sa parole
1 milliards sur le dos des départements
on a évacué on a fait en sorte d'avoir
les bonnes compensation notamment pour
tout ce qui est un pôle économique ces
feux cvae pour permettre aux
collectivités et notamment au bloc
communal d'avoir des garanties de
ressources pour qu'elles ne soient pas
pénalisés et puis au regard de
l'activité économique et de la crise
sanitaire
il nous est apparu que certains secteurs
d'activité je pense notamment aux
assurances à la vente à distance au
regard des circonstances que j'ai pris
l'initiative de proposer une
contribution exceptionnelle et c'est le
1 % sur les assurances c'est également
l'un portant sur la vente à distance par
rapport à leur chiffre d'affaires avec
un seul objectif alimenter la solidarité
interprofessionnelle entre les acteurs
économiques